[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone my name is joe sasso i'm a
chef here in los angeles california and
today i'm going to show you my family's
recipe for ultimate lasagna
i wanted to make lasagna because in my
family when you think of the holidays
it's always lasagna whether it's
thanksgiving or christmas sure we'll
have turkey but the main event is always
the lasagna so holiday times
this is the recipe that is closest to my
heart
so mixing together the eggs the flour
and the spinach powder a little bit of
salt kneading that together for about 20
minutes until it's nice and smooth
and then you have to give the gluten to
rest give that some time to relax let
those bonds form really strongly
and that way when you go to roll out
your dough it doesn't bounce back on you
it's nice smooth velvety and supple
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
buying
dried pasta and using that they make
some really good ones out there but
there's something special about making
pasta by hand it's a tactile experience
you're putting
your love and your labor into this
product and then you're sharing it
directly with your family with your
friends
so if you have the opportunity to make
fresh pasta you're doing something
special like lasagna
might as well go the distance and go all
in
the entire sheeting process may look
very intimidating it's not at all if you
have a good dough and it's needed
properly and rested properly the
sheeting process in laminating actually
goes very easily
so as you're cutting your sheets for
your lasagna obviously take a look at
the baking dish that you're going to use
you can use any size that you'd like
just make sure you're cutting your
sheets to fit the size of your baking
dish
bechamel are one of those base sauces
that's used in a number of different
applications all over the world
essentially it's
milk or cream thickened with a roux
flour and butter that acts as our nice
white creamy rich sauce that's going to
go in between the layers of our lasagna
your bechamel should thicken as soon as
it comes to a boil once it's boiling or
simmering you want to give it another
two or three minutes just to cook off
any of that raw flour taste that still
might be in there
so growing up in an italian household
it's all about family and it's all about
food we start eating from the moment we
wake up till the moment we take a nap
then we wake up keep eating again so
lasagna
was always that main event sometimes
we'd have it in the afternoon round two
then we'll have the main dinner with the
turkey or the roast beef and then
maybe another slice of lasagna before
bed but to me lasagna was always that
that center piece
so the biggest thing for me when you're
making gravy is you don't want these
giant meat nuggets all throughout your
sauce
when you meat first goes into the pan
whether it be with a whisk or a spoon
make sure to break up all those chunks
so it's nicely uniformed ground beef and
that way that'll coat your entire pasta
and you won't get these big pockets and
big chunks of meat throughout
to me making and eating lasagna's love
always remember eat pasta make love
and the meat sauce is definitely the
base to the lasagna you know i think
they're you could tell a lot about the
way someone grew up is whether they call
it red sauce or gravy in my family gravy
was this it's tomato sauce with the meat
and the veggies and everything cooked in
it for a number of hours but that's what
gravy is not that brown stuff you put on
roast beef that's different
this is gravy you could call it red
sauce whatever you want to call it it's
really good
so moving into the blanching of the
pasta
have your pot of salted boiling water
those go in for about 30 to 60 seconds
into an ice bath that's going to
immediately stop the cooking process and
transfer it to some parchment paper
sprayed with non-stick spray you want to
make sure to get non-stick spray between
each layer and on top of each layer
otherwise you're going to run into
problems later when you're assembling
assembling the lasagna organization is
going to be the key to happiness while
you're putting together lasagna making
sure all of your ingredients are lined
up room temperature chilled you don't
want to build a lasagna with hot sauce
or hot bechamel it's just going to be a
mess it's not going to work take the
time to do these things ahead and that
way it's all ready to go when it's time
to assemble
don't worry about trimming any
overlapping edges or any pasta hanging
out of the sides
that leads to a golden brown and
delicious rim
your entire family will fight over them
mine did it was the most sought after
part of the entire lasagna
my favorite step is watching it come out
of the oven and then it's a true test of
patience because you can't eat it
immediately you have to let it cool for
i would say at the minimum 15 minutes if
you give it a half an hour that's even
better because it's molten hot in there
and you're doing yourself a favor by
waiting it'll hold together when you go
and cut it and it'll be that much more
enjoyable having to wait
to then eat the pasta
so good
it's like childhood all over again
as an adult
eating the crispy bits it's the part
everybody used to fight over and they're
all mine
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you